euh ah on va revenir tiens vous savez
que Bernard Montiel va faire une
nouvelle émission sur C8 ah bon les
grands du rire oui ah oui bah c'est lui
qui anime on on a pris le plus vieux euh
le le plus petit et le moins
drôle on a pris le plus vieux bah oui
bien sûr et il va animer grand du rire
bientôt ce sera le weekend
et il y a kry Moro dans ces médiatiques
émission que que personne ne regarde
mais très sympa non mais c'est très
sympa qui a dit qui recevu Jean-Luc l
moine et qui a donné une fausse info
donc étant donné qu'on un petit peu de
médiia dans cette émission je suis
obligé de redonner les bonnes infos en
tant que membre de C8 voilà pour
donner regarder voilà et après je
donnerai la vérité j'en ai rat le cul de
ces horaires oh là possible été c'est là
tloisir annonc le retour de l'émission
Les Grands du rire sur C8 avec Bernard
Montiel c'est l'émission qui a été sur
votre case pendant 16 ans a priori des
désormais programmé face à vous le
samedi après-midi vous le prenez comment
je trouve dommage que ce public qui est
en demande de program comme ça on leur
propose un programme qui pourrait leur
plaire au même moment sur deux chaînes
différentes je comprends pas la logique
de venir en frontal peut-être que y AEL
chose vous ennuyez peut-être je pense
que les deux émissions peuvent répondre
à une demande c'est dommage de la mettre
en face alors kierry Mor qui le fou de
merde il dit pour vous emmerder déjà
Thierry quand tu fais une interview boss
avant mon chéri oh sans rigoler c'est
c'est je sais que c'est França 5 c'est
pas sérieuxon dès qu'ils font une
enquête France Télévision ils sont à
côté de la plaque mais là franchement
mon chéri ça sera pas en face des grand
du rire c'est vrai c'est exact ça sera
pas en face de samedi dans rire les
grand du rire tu sais à quelle heure je
vais te mettre ah oui mais on peut pas
le dire encore voilà mais tu seras pas
en face vous le savez mais en tout cas
c'est pas en face voilà donc il a dit
n'importe quoi exactement mais où estce
trouvé l'info il y a pas d'info surtout
certainement dans son cul ni C8 ni
personne n'a communiqué sur les horaires
on na jamais communiqué sur les horaires
l'oraire je le connais moi bah oui je
sais que vous le connaissez mais toi tu
le connais non bah je te le dirai un
jour derer au courant on a déjà tourné
quatre émissions peux dire avec Karen ch
T 4 non non tourner 6 la semaine
prochaine mais t déjà ce que tu dois
tourner ça plît beaucoup hein à la
direction B je l'ai pas vu vous l'z pas
vu
vous alors alors là c'est je vient de
commîre un unère ils ont aimé je crois
il vous allez aimer vous allez aim il m
pas dit ça et en plus vous savez ce que
j'ai dit dans la presse aujourd'hui
c'est sorti de semaines gentil ouais oui
j'ai dit non j'ai dit c'est vous qui
m'aviez proposé en premier ouais c'est
qui alors ta
mère c'est vrai je pensais pas vousti
concerné aussi par ça al là moi qui l'ai
lancé et ben oui mais c'est une bonne
idée et ce qu'il faut dire quand même
c'est que les grand ça existit les grand
ça existait avant Sam
derniy vous êtes j'ai que c'est vous qui
m'avez proposé en plus gentillesse ouais
le mois d'O c'est vous qui m'avez prop
rajoute pas Bernard ne rajoute pas pas
j'ai disriement t' appé le mois d'oût
moi oui moi je t'ai appelé moi non non
mais pas appelé c'est qui m'a dit tiens
c'est Sir Mme t'a proposé d'ord je vous
appelle pas c'est bon non non mais ça va
tu prends un peu d'oseil avec ça pas du
tout c'est bien je suis content
voilà exactement les directives que
j'avais donné très clairement voilà
c'est le plaisir c'est le plaisir de
travailler mais bon oui pas de quoi
s'acheter un pantalon à pince
c'est ça hein tu es content non mais
l'émission fait plaisir c'est une très
bonne émission on est en train de
retravailler les weekends là donc tu
auras Bernard Montiel avec Karine
cherine Karine Isabelle mauis que
j'embrasse Isabelle également une amie
et et on est en train de retravailler
les weekend ah ah il va y avoir d'autres
choses pour janvier on arriver oui
peut-être avec ma personne oh ça
charbonne ah ouais le samedi ou le
dimanche j'ai du mal à boucler les fins
de
mois j'ai pas mal de projets qui
arrivent donc voilà non non c'est il est
possible après j'ai pas encore je suis
en train de travailler sur des choses
avec la direction de la Chaîne avec
vousmême
quoi avec son papier avec son reflet
train de travailler sur des choses avec
notamment mon ami franc CAPI président
avec Gérard brisevir mon ami avec
Vincent puol et Alexandre Israël je
leurais dit que j'avais envie de faire
quelque chose samedi et dimanche je fais
ce que je
veux donc on va voir ce sera peut-être
samedi sera peut-être dimanche voilà
mais on est en train de travailler avec
lonel Stan également le directeur
général l'â de eau puis qu'on va
retravailler les weekends il sont il
sont un peu plus difficiles pour nous
pour C V donc on a lancé Bernard Montiel
on y croit pas de fou mais on l'a
lancé
non
[Applaudissements]
ça ça va ê très
bien très bne ém t'exlique c'est mé
c'est moi qui te l'ai envoyé donc je te
le dis j'y crois à fond donc on va
refaire le producteur on va refaire les
samedis et les dimanches et il est
possible que j'apparaisse sur quelque
chose un nouveau paille qui va arriver
mais vous serez payé comme Bernard
Montiel ce sera gratos pas de quoi
acheter un pantalon à pince oui des
nouvelles chaussures non non je serai
producteur de l'émission ah d'accord
donc après s'il reste quelque chose on
le partagera entre nous voilà à la
bonnequette et on verra ce qu'on peut
faire non non non non oui bonsoir la
semaine sur C8 il y a beaucoup de
d'après-midi pour les personnes âgées on
est d'accord vous pensez à Bernard je
vous propose un truc jeune pour le
weekend ouais est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
organiser des espèces de soirées pyjama
le samedi soir oou on papote entre nous
des trucs un peu plus un peu plus jeunes
vou couler la chaîne
non ça pourit être ça pourrait être
chouette voulez couler la chaîne non pas
du tout ça ne marchera jamais donc on
fait que des trucs pour les vieux si
vous dites ça pour Bernard Montien mais
dor d'abord du respect les seigneors on
dit et puis ils sont tout aant
responsable pourquoi vousz mettre à
quelle heure votre truc le soir vous
croyez vraiment que je vais mettre 23h30
jeis mettre de l'argent il y a quoi
23h30 il y a rien parce que aujourd'hui
d aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les gens les
gens les gens font rien non non mais je
vous le dis non non non on fer en vérité
pour lui répondre 1 srius jamais on
mettra de l'argent à 23h30 17h bah non
ça sert à rien on préfère faire une
redif de quelque chose qui Fa autant
d'audience que votre soirée pyjama si ce
n'est plus
diman dimanche à 17h30 il y a pas un
trousmi bien dimanche à 17h30 croyez
vraiment que je vais mettre de l'argent
dimanche à 17h30 alors que j'ai les
animaux j'ai j'ai on a les animaux qui
marchent très bien March très bien en
revanche on va peut-être travailler une
autre case et quelle heure est fait
blarde alors le weekend l'accès du
weekend est fait Blard soit le samedi ou
le dimanche c'estd le 19h 21h voilà
après il faut trouver quelqu'un qui
veille bien le faire à moindre cût donc
voilà combien je suis en train de
chercher voilà donc vous
serez on vous
consul consultera je dis cons pour
l'instant voilà pour l'instant non pour
l'instant c'est non bien franchement
je alors le problème c'est qu' vu le
truc qu'on va faire c'est pas une
animation pour Raymon je P d'cord un
truc avec én indice sur la thématique
c'est pas un jeu non non mais c'est
visiblement pour cyile
to vous emmerdez pas c'est pour moi un
jeu présenté par vous non non mais vous
emmerdez pas je peux pas dire ce que
c'est on en train de voir c'est pas sûr
que ça se fasse ah on est en train de
voir en train de faire les budgets de
tirer les budgets c'est pas évident on
essaie de faire la meilleure grriille
pour les téléspectateurs et c'est vrai
que le dimanche et le samedi on on
trouve qu'on est un petit peu en dessous
voilà on va voir la semaine marche très
bien et on est en train de travailler
également sur la GRE de janvier il y
aura des nouveautés ah les nouveautés
don Bernard Montiel encore je le
rappelle ça fait longtemps qu'on avait
pas dit que j'étais une
nouveauté